so
i started reality check which is a very
no
it's got the highest success rate of any
program in the country what is it
i built when i got out of prison a guy
comes up to me
golfer says hey larry i need a favor i
said [ __ ] you you want me to break
somebody's legs i just got out of
[ __ ] prison
leave me the [ __ ] alone he says no no no
he goes i caught my 16 year old smoking
weed and he said [ __ ] you dad where have
you been
now i smoke weed i'm i'm a believer in
all drugs right
just if you commit a crime to do them
right
that's what you're saying but what you
do in your own house dan i don't give a
[ __ ] what you're not hurting anybody
what you do in your own house is your
business right nobody should ever
[ __ ]
judge you or talk yeah that's not what i
believe in matter that's why i'm a
libertarian now
right but anyway uh so
uh he said i said your son told you
where to [ __ ] you
i'll talk to your son you want to talk
about having
the stars aligned i have pictures of
me in prison with gangsters
[ __ ] murderers [ __ ] gang members
everything you know friends and you you
can't do that anymore
so it was just the timing was perfect
back when i was in you could take those
pictures uh-huh
can't do that today so i take these
pictures over to the kid
nah he's a big kid but i'm a pretty big
guy
intimidating if you want to understand
that you know what i mean
yeah oh yeah for sure so i sit down to
the kid and i said
i only used two curse words i said
you told your father where the [ __ ] he's
been let me show you where the [ __ ] i
just came from
kid looked at me i started i don't
believe in that first of all
that's a great story too i don't believe
it's scared straight
it doesn't work because if i yelled at
you you'd look at me where the [ __ ] is
this idiot
[ __ ] shut down and i gotta get out of
here right you know i mean
okay little [ __ ] you never understand
me but if i told you a story about a kid
who got his anus cut from the top of his
ass to his balls
and raped and [ __ ] seminal fluid was
found in there
and i read the articles and heard the
screams you will never forget that
you probably won't now or audience but i
tell the whole exact
story but anyway right so i started
telling the kids stories and showing
them the pictures
i was there for about an hour and a half
whatever it was i i'm just out of prison
and the father's a golf i'm a golfer and
you play golf yeah
do you yes man oh let's go let's go play
golf after this man let's
play nine holes if i didn't have my golf
clubs now i know you're here
yeah i used to be very good i used to be
a three now now i'm at
about 10 12. i suck i'm i'm yeah i'm not
good i can gauze and drink
exactly oh you're in we're playing we're
golfing we're playing golf
definitely now i have another reason to
come oh hell yeah man
oh i love it and so we're sitting there
and uh
uh i talked to the kid i go out to the
gazebo the guy's a golf pro
and he says to me he goes there i
appreciate it whatever
and gives me money gives me a hundred
bucks i think
that's man he goes i know you just got
out of prison whatever give me a hundred
bucks
calls me two weeks later now you know i
got my law degree from prison
now i have the credits to be a lawyer i
don't have the degree
right because i'm a convicted felon
right but i'm a licensed paralegal
i did law for 10 years in prison so when
i get out i was gonna go work with a
couple
law firms easily do it now did you do
that
to did you help out a lot of other
people oh all the time
every day i hear like jailhouse lawyers
you call jailhouse lawyers
is the reason that i've heard that the
reason a lot of people do that
is so they can have some sort of value
to other people in there so people won't
[ __ ] with them
you might not have been worried about
that but i know i understand what you're
saying uh
you know do they do it as protection
yeah most people do
the guys who i know do and i have a very
good friend of mine who does one of the
best in the country
paul tulini and uh i just did a video
with him and he got
two guys out with life sentences in the
last month damn with life sentences
guys the best and you know it's about
writing and how to do it we understand
the laws and the courts
most of us do it for the right reasons
yeah you'll get some of it but
they're idiots then they they get
exposed for not being good at what they
do
you got to love the law and you got to
love doing it
to live in that law library and stuff i
used to fight the system
i'm going to tell you that's when i told
you i went crazy in the hole and all
that
but anyway so uh the kid uh
the law the uh father says calls me two
weeks later he goes larry i don't know
what you did you just forget your law
forget anything you got to work with
kids
my kid said dad i don't want to go where
that guy we missed a lot and went
i need help i need help
16 years kids great i was 12 years 13
years ago kids 30 married
college degree everything wow and he
goes
can i give your name out sure
people give me a hundred bucks just talk
to that kid i said [ __ ] this is great
man what the [ __ ] you know but i loved
it because you're helping somebody
i always love to help people and
so as i'm doing that i get a phone call
from a lady named jean bandish she's
from the juvenile court coordinator in
brevard county
and she says hey mr lawton uh judge
reimer would like to see you
ain't going to see no [ __ ] judge she
goes no no she wants it i said i'll give
a [ __ ] you got a warrant
you gotta you don't gotta want it i
think you're gonna [ __ ] i know the
law
yeah she goes no no no no she wants to
know what you do i said listen i ain't
doing anything illegal
i'm [ __ ] helping people i don't want
no that's what she wants to know
i still don't want to go in a courthouse
who [ __ ] wants to go to the
courthouse right
she convinces me that they just want to
talk to me about the program
and i go in there on a friday so
friday comes i go in there i don't even
know how to [ __ ] work a computer
i don't know [ __ ] now i'm pretty tech
but
i didn't know anything my nephew who
since passed
he shows me how to do a powerpoint helps
me put a powerpoint i don't know
10 slide 15 slide power point the [ __ ]
uses power points now i don't know but
anyway
it's a power point and i go in there and
i show them everything
and it just goes oh thank you would you
like to stay for the rest of the minutes
no
get the [ __ ] out of here i don't feel
good man i'm in the [ __ ]
judges chambers and every time i'm in
front of a [ __ ] judge i'm going to
prison i spent 12 years 11 years in
prison right 11 straight 12 year
sentences four
12 cents is 11 of they random concurrent
anyway and that's had 11 years so i'm
sitting there and i leave this is a
friday
i get a phone call monday morning genie
says hey
miss lauren how you doing yeah good she
goes i just want to let you know judge
reiman sentenced two people to your
program
what [ __ ] program what do you mean
because your program you know you talked
about it was a
[ __ ] idea in my head
i ended up developing the number one
program
that's been recognized on the floor of
the united states congress
in the country a four-part program that
i still have right now anybody can go on
my website
i sell 35 hours or some [ __ ] you know i
don't try to get people a lot of money
or anything just enough to [ __ ] keep
the internet [ __ ] going right
right and it's a four-part program based
on my life
what prison is really like what you're
gonna lose
and avoiding and dissolving bad
association a four-part program
i developed it in fact i'm the only
ex-con in the united states who's an
honorary cop
really only man in the country i was
sworn in in lake st louis missouri
and i'm no cop lover let me get that
straight cops know me
yeah i'm i support good cops right
these [ __ ] cops that harass and got
bully complexes and all the [ __ ]
or hit you for pot or [ __ ] drug that
crap there
get out of the car smell something they
want to find but it's [ __ ]
that's not what america should be about
no do i want a cop
when my house is being broken in
absolutely yep 911 help me
that's what you bet don't stop me for
some [ __ ]
i even came up with a couple of policies
that i don't think cops should ever be
allowed to stop you for anything that's
non-life-threatening
meaning if you're going 100 miles an
hour down the street yeah you're gonna
hurt somebody
but if you're going five miles an hour
over the limit
you wanna give me a ticket give me a
ticket they can take your license plate
with the car
uh car camera right
send me a ticket if you make a right
turn and don't put your single light on
they shouldn't stop you
right they should give you if they wanna
they could take a picture
boom give you a ticket because once they
stop you everything happens you're
you might have a little pot in the car
some [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what i do
oh am i gonna run i'm a dick i'm not
saying you're somebody
you know what i mean i want you and once
you're in the system for one thing it's
a vicious cycle you could it's
so hard to escape it because they have
you these oh this guy's already been
busted for this this this and this
we're [ __ ] nailing this guy you're a
hundred percent right man you are a
hundred percent
and it's wrong